[Music]
thank you
now a brutal conflict has broken out
again in Sudan in Khartoum in recent
days and the big media story here has
been understandably how do we get
British citizens out of there and the
government's various efforts to evacuate
British possible holders and British
workers from Sudan however a lot of
people are also interested in how this
conflict began and the various
complicated dynamics of Sudan which have
largely been overlooked in recent years
so I'm delighted to be joined by Dr
Chirino hitang ofuo who is a former
minister in the south of Sudan and he's
joining us now from Kenya Dr Chirino
thank you very much for joining us
most welcome
um well let's start uh with this latest
eruption of violence how did we get here
how did this conflict start give our
viewers a little history of what's going
on
thank you in fact this is the most
unfortunate uh event in recent history
that uh a war just broke out
unexpectedly because uh however the
crisis have been going on there have
been a lot of differences between the
rsf and uh and the Sudanese Army uh uh
or since the the fall of albashir
eventually uh emerged as a force that
was coming to stabilize the aftermath of
the series collapse from power and uh
unfortunately the rsf became a
prevailing and dominant military force
in in in Khartoum and particularly
within the center of power in uh in in
her tomb first
there was a cooperation between uh
burhan president
eventually because they work together in
davul for over many years and so people
so that as maybe something that can
bring good working relationship between
the two unfortunately for ideological
reasons these people fell out
particularly when they took over power
from the from the civilian rule under
prime minister hamdock
yeah in short really uh it was never
expected that this brutal law could uh
could could happen between burhan and
hemeti and rightly so because behind it
really which many people do not see and
do not know and maybe by now they have
known is behind this is actually the
islamist the the the the islamist who
were under albashir the the the national
Islamic front and they are still there
they were hibernating behind and and
they took advantage of this and
triggered the the crisis between uh
bruhan and uh and and hemetic and this
is where uh
many people are shocked attacking by
shock particularly Sudanese themselves
those the experts who know the Sudanese
politics Will really find out that this
was totally something that came up like
that struck like lightning between the
two but it is really the islamists who
were behind it who want to come back to
Power in the in in the Sudan who were
very upset with uh with the emergence of
hemetry and particularly the rsf and
that's why they reverted them as militia
and they don't really look at them as a
military uh Force like the Sudanese Army
who are very proud uh military who look
at themselves as an army a strong Army
in the country that fought many wars
that was able to defend the country
against uh the splm John garang's Sudan
people's Liberation movements Liberation
Army a very strong Army that built over
20 years that they resisted that and
they were able to stand and until they
signed peace and the South broke out
well
um the the rasf uh we understand grew
out of the janjaweed who uh did become
internationally recognized a few years
ago because they were terrorizing
particularly Christians in the south of
Sudan
um
how uh is it correct to see the rsf the
rapid support forces as uh the more
vicious islamist uh faction
actually the you're right there because
they are actual islamists they were they
were they were initially praying as
islamists they actually is very thin
line of difference between the rsf and
then and and and the Islam is now who
want to take over power back uh you know
in Sudan in fact we were at the up to
now including hemeti who are still uh
sanctioned by the International
Community because of the atrocities they
committed in Darfur in fact nobody even
expected uh the others have to be
legitimized now uh as the way it
happened after the series collapse from
power
and the the little difference between
the two I think it has to do with the
the tradition of how the Sudanese Army
have been trained uh conventionally and
they look at themselves as a as a
conventional Army unlike the others who
who who are always referred to as uh as
as Prime military uh meaning that they
are not really the same as the Sudanese
Army and and I can agree with you that I
think that the difference are
very thin between the rsf when it comes
to Islamic ideology
and an oddity of of this conflict has
been that it's broken out during the end
of Ramadan which is meant to be a time
of peace and reflection absolutely in
fact on a Friday I I'm told on the 14th
on a Friday they had a dinner and uh one
of the leaders of the of the transient
council is a general Malik agar who is
the leader from Blue Nile who was
organizing to mediate between hemeti and
uh and brohan and really did not expect
this crisis to to break out especially
during our Ramadan it was still shocking
even to people like you know Malik agar
he never expected that this war was
going to happen because he was one of
the mediators and uh he he has always
tried to play this role of being a
moderate and and and having the stlm
sbla background and now one of the
leaders of the skeletonos so Malik was
not really Keen to see this kind of of
crisis I'm holding
and how do people in the South you're
from the south how do people in the
South feel about this uh conflict
between what seems to be uh rival uh
Islamic or islamist groups in the North
is a very interesting question because
actually many people in the South are
divided there are many who are
sympathetic to the situation but also
successful majority who have never
forgiven the north but what they did to
the South have said okay let them test
the salt of wood they have always
imposed on the south it is uh it is
unfortunate that many Southerners of
that nature could could look like essay
let us see the north boil into this
because they have always put us in the
South under similar circumstances but
the majority of of Southerners also who
are totally much who probably spend a
lot of their time growing and doing a
lot of business or having gone to
schools in the north real feel the
sympathy of what has happened but
otherwise there are others in the South
who says yes let them knows does it for
for over 50 years the South has been
subjected uh by by Northern Sudanese
Elites under similar circumstances
and what about the involvement of uh
outside Powers uh I mean I think in the
west uh there was a lot of
concern about Darfur but perhaps we
turned our attention away from it
because it seemed to have settled down
there seemed to be some sort of
political
um settlement and now there's a lot of
talk in in Western media about the role
of Russia
um because of uh I think the world group
seeming to have some connection with the
Russian mercenary group seeming to have
some connection with the rsf
um
is this a case of Russia and the West
sort of squabbling for power or is it
more complicated than that no I think
okay I think there has been uh of course
that Scramble for Africa they call it
now maybe you call it as another
struggle a Scramble for Africa where
Russia versus the West uh I have been
seen uh playing different roles but I
think uh there has been a larger
involvement of uh of the rsf leader
particular hemeti with uh with Russia
and with other Middle East Powers mainly
based on his engagement in business in
trade he is is a very big businessman
this Hampden
has been he is actually monopolize a
gold business in uh in in Darfur in in
the Sudan and and has has become the
center of attention required by Russia
and he has a connection even though
as we have all seen now it's not secret
and uh so hemiti has really had a lot of
business with uh with Russia other than
the West like uh Britain or uh or the
United States of America
you mentioned gold uh Sudan is a very
resource-rich country uh obviously this
is a very another troubling phase for it
but what do you think is a is an
optimistic scenario for the future how
could this be settled
Sudan is really very very volatile
and I think that uh many people never
expected it as I said it before and uh
the the attitude of the leaders now if
you look at the Quran versus
they have just signed this Armitage
these truth just for to allow the
evacuation of uh uh foreigners from
Sudan but they are not giving room they
have never given any signal of giving
room for any talks or any negotiations
so for some of us an analyst who know uh
similar conflicts we we I'm very worried
that it could turn out like a Yemen or
Syria
um
so I'm actually impressed also by the
response of the West uh particularly
Britain and the United States of America
in particularly Britain for that matter
having been the the colonial power upon
Sudan and uh and and a government that
has Associated itself with Sudan for a
long time that they have responded quite
uh uh very fast and and bring large
attention and you hear uh British
foreign secretary the U.S Secretary of
State all at least on daily basis have
given a lot of their time to release and
I think that's an impressive part from
that perspective
Dr turiano thank you very much for
coming on to spectator TV
[Music]